wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
[Applaus]
möchtest du etwas essen was gibt es dann
so wie pizza seiner art ok nico was
möchtest du essen
ich möchte eine pizza bitte das ist die
speisekarte von unserem lieblings
italiener danke nico das ist nach wie
nico hallo ich bin nico nico bist du der
nikos im radio nico war im radio
du suchst eine tasche ja die speisekarte
was nehmt ihr ich möchte das jetzt auch
grafisch sehr gut ich nehme auch eine
pizza mit salami und nico möchtest du
eine pizza mit thunfisch einem mit
salami oder eine mit mozzarella
ich nehme eine pizza mit salami bitte
und ich nehme mir immer meine pizza
hawaii ohne schinken bitte
das ist eine pizza mit ananas und
schinken nina mit einer nazi ist aber
vegetarierin und es hätten sie die pizza
jedes mal ohne schinken so und ich
bestelle
wo ist mein handy eine nachricht auf
book das foto